bonsoir à tous et merci d'être avec nous
en ce vendredi soir pour une heure de
reportage et d'enquête autour de
l'actualité de la région des découvertes
aussi c'est le retour de l'enquête au
centre saisons 4 et voici le sommaire de
ce numéro
les tours en jouets sont très fiers
c'est ici paraît-il dans le Val de Loire
compare le meilleur français avec le
meilleur accent mais s'agit-il d'un
mythe ou d'une réalité ce qui est bien
réel en tout cas c'est que le parler
local a servi de modèle pour poser les
bases de la langue française et
qu'aujourd'hui encore de nombreuses
étrangers choisissent en priorité la
Touraine pour apprendre le français
ils veulent vivre et travailler au pays
mais pour les jeunes agriculteurs du
Berry c'est de plus en plus difficile
ces dernières années le prix des terres
n'a cessé d'augmenter les exploitations
s'agrandissent ce qui empêche
l'installation de nouveaux exploitants
on a des structures qui sont de moins en
moins transmissibles comprenez les
structures qui arrivent à 5 6 7 5 quand
vous voulez qu'un jeune ils reprennent
ça c'est pas possible c'est impossible
il y a quelques temps de là on avait des
domaines enfermage qu'un jeune pourrait
s'installer dessus sur 80 hectares
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est plus le
cas on trouve plus cher c'est les
grosses structures des grosses
structures des grosses structures quoi
faut-il ouvrir les magasins le dimanche
et en soirée pour certaines grandes
enseignes et de nombreux élus le
phénomène est inéluctable mais à la base
des syndicats des travailleurs résistent
pour préserver leur qualité de vie
vous avez un planning vous devez le
respecter il n'y a pas de d'alternative
c'est-à-dire que les salariés qui ne
souhaitent pas qui ne souhaitaient pas
aller au-delà de 21h et bien ils étaient
invités à quitter l'entreprise
et si nous avions tous peut-être sans le
savoir un accent sur le bout de la
langue ou au fond du cœur héritage
familial géographique accent gommé au
contraire revendiqué notre manière de
parler la musique de nos maudits
beaucoup de nous mais y a-t-il au fond
un français parfait une langue pure
peut-être bien ici dans le Val de Loire
au 16e siècle c'est entre Touraine et
Orléans que l'on revendiquer de parler
le meilleur François Le touranjo Alfred
de Vigny l'écrivait lui aussi le berceau
de la langue est là près du berceau de
la monarchie mais pourquoi et comment
cet accent là est-il devenu au fil des
siècles la norme celui qui s'est imposé
comme référence et qui s'exporte
aujourd'hui dans le monde entier
l'accent des gens d'ici c'est un
magazine de Xavier nézé pierre Dominique
lepet et David jouya mignonne allons
voir si la rose qui ce matin avait des
clauses sa robe de pourpre au soleil à
point perdu cette vesprée les plis de sa
robe pour près et sont à votre pareil
l'as voyez comment peu d'espace mignonne
est là dessus la place place ces beautés
les séchoirs oh vraiment marâtre nature
puisqu'une telle fleur ne dure que du
matin jusqu'au soir
donc si vous me croyez mignonne tandis
que votre âge florone en sa plus verte
nouveauté cueillait cueillez votre
jeunesse comme à cette fleur la
vieillesse fera ternir votre beauté
en 155 à l'époque où Ronsard poète mais
avant dôme est mort à tour écrivait son
note pour la jeune Cassandre qu'il avait
rencontré au château de Blois on ne
parlait pas le français de la même
manière qu'aujourd'hui et on ne parlait
pas encore de Région Centre mais on
disait déjà que c'est dans ces
territoires et dans ces villes situées
entre la Beauce et les bords de Loire
qu'on parlait le meilleur français avec
le meilleur accent
qu'au moment où le français va devenir
une langue de grande diffusion c'est
l'époque de l'édit de Villers-Cotterêts
qui impose le français comme langue
administratif dans pays à partir de ce
moment-là on a tout un travail qui va se
faire il nous faut un modèle de la
langue de référence puisque
Villers-Cotterêts déclare que désormais
le droit sera en français et là on ne
peut pas se permettre d'avoir une langue
fluctuante dans le droit il faut une
langue très ferme donc à la même époque
je crois que villers-cotterait 1539 en
1530 ne vend avant la toute première
grammaire du français dit la langue que
je vais décrire c'est celle qui se parle
entre scène et Loire parce que c'est là
que se parle le meilleur français
à la même époque le tour en jouet
Rabelais écrit Pantagruel récit dans
lequel il est affirmé que la Touraine et
le jardin naturel de la langue française
côté jardin côté cour les rois de France
ont l'habitude de séjourner dans la
région ce qui n'est pas sans rapport
avec le prestige du parler local
alors pourquoi cette cette image là déjà
probablement pour des raisons d'abord le
fleuve royal c'est quand même le modèle
du français du roi puisqu'il faut bien
que le roi parle quelque chose la
famille royale s'appelle la famille
d'Orléans c'est là encore tout un tout
un symbole mais il y a aussi une
deuxième probablement idée qui est
derrière c'est que le français qui se
parle là n'est ni le français de Paris
qui a toujours été perçu comme un
français populaire quand on parle de
français parisien c'est très très peu
flatteur en France on pense plutôt à un
vilain accent ni le français des
campagnes donc on est à la fois dans une
culture urbaine qui n'est pas une
culture régionale au sens de la
Normandie ou de la Bourgogne et qui
n'est pas non plus une culture populaire
pour le reste on a des formes très
marquées localement par exemple une qui
est très étrange
très étrange pendant pour quelqu'un qui
étudie l'histoire du français c'est la
forme nous sommes
quand on conjugue le verbe Être qui est
très irrégulier on a bien une forme je
suis qui est très particulière tu es
vous êtes etc mais la forme somme avec
ce M est très étrange vous savez que
c'est le seul verbe Français qui n'a pas
une forme en à la première personne du
pluriel on doit avoir je sons tous les
autres verbes nous chantons nous
finissons nous allons nous partons nous
voulons etc tous une forme en haut mais
ça c'est un trait tout à fait
particulier de la région Centre nous
sommes
mais après tu vois en neige pourquoi
cette faveur pourquoi se privilège et si
je vous disais après tout le sens du
Nord que c'est vous qui pour nous
sembler l'avoir très fort que nous
disions de vous durant la Gironde ces
gens-là n'ont pas le parler de tout le
monde et que tout dépendant de la façon
de voir le pas avoir d'accent pour nous
c'est en avoir je n'y vais aucun
journaux
aucun journaux le seul journal que je
mets le nez dessus une fois par semaine
quand je peux l'avoir c'est un journal
de bourse
de compréhension qui est lié à l'accent
notamment sur le sur le mot bourse
parle-t-on encore dans la région à
français de meilleures qualités
qu'ailleurs c'est l'une des questions
qui étudie les chercheurs du laboratoire
ligérien de linguistique il travaille à
partir de deux séries d'enregistrements
l'une effectue en 1968 par des
universitaires britanniques et l'autre
en cours de réalisation toujours à
Orléans
pour un truc qui est vraiment pas cool
alors c'est intéressant ce que chips
c'est un mot qu'on entend pas énormément
mais qu'on entend à Orléans point
socialiste comme moi la réalité de
meilleurs français est un peu délicate à
manier sur un plan scientifique il n'y a
pas de meilleur français il y a des par
contre il y a un Français qui vaut
peut-être plus cher qu'un autre et le
rapport qu'on les Français avec la
langue c'est que ce qui vaut le plus
cher c'est ce qui est le plus proche de
la norme le plus proche de l'écrit le
plus proche du français standard alors
effectivement quand on est dans cette
position là on recherche ce qui est le
plus proche du standard ce qui est ce
qui ressemble le plus à ce qu'on entend
à la télévision ce qui ressemble le plus
aux paroles des personnes des
portes-paroles autorisées des
journalistes des hommes politiques et
donc là
enclin évidemment à aller vers un
endroit où l'accent ne semble pas très
marqué à l'oreille mais c'est c'est pas
meilleur français
le tien c'est le tien et le mien c'est
le mien l'accent
l'accent de la télé ne signifie rien
imposé par les infos il déteigne tous
les pays bonnes prennent le sien oublie
le leur est-ce que ça te convient
complètement aliéné soudaine face au
micro alors il n'y a plus rien peur de
l'accent qui viennent d'où tu viens et
pourtant il t'appartiennent le tien
c'est le tien et le mien c'est le mien
l'accent
cinq siècles après Rabelais et Ronsard
le français parlé dans le Val de Loire
jouit toujours de la même réputation
flatteuse entre Amboise loches et Tours
la Touraine héberge 600 entre
spécialisés dans l'apprentissage du
français pour étranger le plus
prestigieux et l'Institut de Touraine
fondé en 1912 il accueille des
stagiaires de 80 nationalités
différentes pour des formations plus ou
moins intensives ce qui suivent ce cours
sont des débutants au début d'une
formation prévue pour un mois certains
ont déjà pris quelques cours dans leur
pays d'autres partent de zéro
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait samedi je
suis allée au carrefour j'ai fait
l'écorce
des monstres
j'ai
entré
mais mes amis d'accord donc vous avez
rencontré des amis et vous avez raconté
beaucoup d'histoires d'accord
Amal prépare un diplôme de psychologie
au Qatar c'est son université qui l'a
orienté vers l'Institut
moi
si je prends les Slaves que je connais
particulièrement bien on sait qu'on sait
que leur fréquence la fréquence des
Slaves étant donné le spectre il est
beaucoup plus facile pour eux d'attraper
l'accent français pur pour d'autres
nationalités ce sera peut-être un peu
plus difficile en particulier peut-être
pour des étudiants arabophones qui ont
je dirais
qu'ils n'ont pas certaines voyelles donc
il faudra effectivement qu'ils imaginent
ces voyelles donc il faudra une très
bonne articulation par rapport à ça mais
c'est vrai que il est plus facile
peut-être d'apprendre le français à
Tours que d'apprendre le français
peut-être à Montpellier mais en même
temps le français de Montpellier est un
très beau français
les étudiants qui suivent cette
formation d'un mois sont répartis en une
vingtaine de groupes selon leur niveau
et ce jour-là les plus avancés
travaillent au laboratoire
on va essayer de travailler la prosodie
vous ne connaissez pas le mot
la phonétique s'oppose à la prosodie la
phonétique c'est la prononciation ils
sont
alors que la prosodie c'est ce qui
enveloppe la langue célèbre nation c'est
le rythme ce sont les accents
d'insistance autrement dit c'est ce
qu'on appelle c'est ce qui donne entre
autres l'accent français
que les enfants de notre pays valent les
langues
et qu'est-ce que tu trouves le plus
difficile dans dans l'apprentissage du
français évidemment c'est l'accent non
je sais pas
peut-être non
des choses les plus les plus difficiles
difficiles d'apprendre c'était la
recommandation ou la conseil de le
conseil de mon prof en Angleterre et il
a dit que en fait la tour on parle
le type de français le plus pur
du tout le monde francophone et alors je
suis venu ici et c'est sympa
la jeune femme qui vient
d'arriveras et les ressortissants du
Golf Persique sont de plus en plus
nombreux ces dernières années la
population de l'Institut évolue en
fonction du dynamisme économique des
continents car ces études ont un coût en
dehors de l'hébergement il faut compter
près de 1000 euros pour une formation
d'un mois et 7000 pour la session
annuelle
alors on a pas mal de pays de gens qui
viennent du Moyen-Orient parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de bourses de mobilité pour les
étudiants des pays du Golf notamment on
a des gens qui viennent d'Extrême-Orient
notamment Corée Japon Taïwan avec des
projets d'études à la pierre
alors on a eu des rois des princes et
des princesses mais enfin c'est pas le
fonds de commerce quand même de
l'Institut le dernier exemple que j'ai
c'était une princesse thaïlandaise qui
était venue il y a quelques années voilà
mais non on n'est pas un nid de royauté
un institut de Torrent
en plus des cours les étudiants peuvent
aussi participer à des ateliers
thématiques consacrés à la culture
française sous tous ses aspects par
exemple dégustation de vin et de fromage
de nos belles provinces
dans la région les fromages les plus
connus
d'appellation d'origine contrôlée il y a
que des chèvres et on a beaucoup de vin
blanc aussi dans la région et l'accord
des deux c'est très bien
par contre pour un camembert ou du brie
on va plutôt boire du vin rouge ici il
ne s'agit pas seulement de goûter des
produits mais aussi d'enrichir son
vocabulaire en lien avec le thème du
jour la gastronomie ça c'est du vin
blanc mais la couleur c'est jaune
déjà dans le dans les vins blancs il
existe plusieurs sortes de jaune ça
c'est un jaune
pâle vous comprenez PAL c'est vous êtes
sortis place plumeau déjà
je crois que dans l'esprit des
fondateurs dès le départ il y avait
l'idée de faire des étrangers des
ambassadeurs de la Touraine donc c'est
déjà une vision je dirais assez
innovante pour l'époque c'était non
seulement à prendre le français mais
après rester acquis à la Touraine pour
la vie
non
pas loué
la Touraine le chanteur iranien tari
agbary et son ami ira car il y a Jawad
n'ont jamais pu s'en détacher ils
habitent toujours ici plus de 30 ans
après leur rencontre dans une salle de
classe de l'Institut à l'époque où le
conflit entre leurs deux pays était sur
le point de débuter
qu'on essayait de communiquer ensemble
et parler ensemble avec très très peu de
moyens en fait des petits mots
qu'on avait on faisait de conversation
politique des débats sur la politique
parce que tout était politisé on était
tous vraiment très très politisés à
cette époque dans les années 80 très
très rapidement la guerre a commencé on
était encore étudiant à la
question si vous étiez resté dans vos
pays tous les deux vous auriez pu être
amenés à faire la guerre oui
certainement
on va commencer l'histoire sur le front
mais c'est le destin
il faut partir à Tours
je suis arrivé directement ici pour
trouver à quel endroit je vais faire mon
apprentissage de la langue française en
fait je suis venu appuyer de la gare de
Tours jusqu'ici en demandant en
regardant sur un plan où on m'avait
dessiné je suis venu à pied pour trouver
ce temple de la langue française là où
j'ai fait en fait ma mon apprentissage
de la langue française et voilà que des
souvenirs
le charme de la langue française
certaines auront découvert ici au terme
de leur formation d'un mois au moment où
promet de s'écrire au moment des adieux
et pour ça au Qatar des bises on en fait
5 ce qui ne parlait pas un mot en
arrivant ne maîtrise pas encore toutes
les subtilités de la langue de chez nous
mais au moins à mal peut nous parler en
français
merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup beaucoup tu parles
français un peu
et ce n'est qu'un au revoir au moment de
partir à mal c'est déjà qu'elle
reviendra à Tours dans quelques mois
pour un séjour plus long
merci beaucoup
l'accent des gens d'ici un magazine de
Xavier pierre Dominique le P et David
jouya avec nous sur ce plateau vous
l'avez vu au début du reportage Gabriel
Bergougnou social linguiste enseignant à
l'université d'Orléans et directeur du
laboratoire ligérien de linguistique
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
qu'est-ce qu'il a de six spécial cet
accent de Val de Loire pour avoir été
choisie comme ça comme modèle
justement qu'il n'est pas spécial c'est
qu'il est apparu comme étant on dit chez
nous non marqué il est pas très pas très
distinctif par rapport à des accents qui
eux paraissaient très marqués comme le
Normand ou le Bourguignon et ça c'est
géographiquement et puis dans la société
c'est aussi un accent qui apparaissait
au moins pour les villes je parle pas
des campagnes comme étant un accent pas
trop populaire à la différence de Paris
qui a très vite concentré une grosse
population ouvrière que même le roi a
fui en allant Versailles ensuite ça
ressemblait à quoi l'accent tour enjeu
au 16e siècle
autant qu'on puisse le reconstituer si
on prend le poème qu'on a entendu tout à
fait au début on aurait plutôt quelque
chose du type
excusez l'accent mignon allons-y la rose
qui ce matin avait des clauses sa robe
de pourpre au soleil n'a point perdu
cette vie pré
ça fait pas un peu québé
cois ça fait un petit peu québécois
parce que ça gardait du Québécois les
oppositions ce qu'on appelle de longueur
de la longueur des voyelles VPN ça a
gardé l'accent tonique et ça a gardé le
rouler celui de la rose
mais le Québécois est un essentiellement
originaire des provinces de l'Ouest il a
encore d'autres traits qu'on a pas ici
par exemple pour dire en québécois
maritime on dira quelque chose comme
Martine qui n'est pas exactement comment
prononcerait ici Gabriel baronnier
est-ce que aujourd'hui
oui bien sûr il y a ce le pire étant
ceux qui n'en n'ont pas bien sûr tout le
monde a un accent sachant qu'on appelle
l'accent aussi bien quelque chose de
géographique comme on vient de le dire
que aussi social le fait je vais aller
très vite et faire dans la caricature
aujourd'hui en France on a ce qu'on
appelle une pause de la voix qui est
centrale dans la bouche si je peux
complètement de l'avant un petit peu
comme si jusqu'en destin ça fait certes
très distinguer mais c'est un accent si
je parle très en arrière ça va faire
paysan
c'est quelque chose qui existe ou qui a
tendance au contraire à se perdre un
petit peu on parle comme on entend
parler vous prenez un ch'ti à trois mois
vous l'amenez à Marseille il parlera
comme à Marseille il y a aucun problème
là-dessus est-ce que maintenant il se
perd oui et pour une raison simple et
c'est votre faute c'est que tout le
monde aujourd'hui a dans l'oreille une
un français standard celui des
journalistes de ceux qu'on entend parler
dans les médias et ces gens-là ont
souvent assez peu l'accent donc on
constate qu'il y a une régression des
accents régionaux en France même en
Belgique d'ailleurs enfin en gros dans
toute la zone au contact avec la France
en Suisse mais en revanche on a un
accroissement une aggravation enfin ce
que c'est grave j'en sais rien de la
différence des accents
par le milieu social on a aujourd'hui
des prononciations très différenciées
probablement liées d'ailleurs à
l'importance en France du mouvement
migratoire qui a eu un effet aussi bien
les pieds noirs dans les années 60 ou
d'autres immigrations depuis alors quand
vous vous parlez avec une personne
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez savoir en tant
que spécialiste qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez savoir d'elle en écoutant son
accent plus largement sa voix sa manière
de parler qu'est-ce que ça dit de votre
interlocuteur
d'abord comme tout le monde on repère
des choses massives mais on a peut-être
un tout petit peu plus l'habitude de
savoir à quoi les assigner alors bien
sûr les accents du midi les accents de
l'Ouest les accents du Nord les accents
de personnes originaires de
l'immigration et qui sont arrivés tard
en France les enfants issus de
l'immigration élevés en France ont pas
spécialement un accent marqué par les
migrations on va identifier comme tout
le monde le sexe de la personne on va
identifier bien sûr avoir un critère sur
son âge ensuite on va avoir des défaits
secondaires mais là il beaucoup
d'éléments perturbent je vais prendre
l'exemple de quelqu'un qui avait quelque
chose que je n'arrivais pas à identifier
dans son accent et au bout d'un moment
je lui ai dit mais il y a un problème tu
fais pas tel type de son le taux de nœud
exactement comme tu devrais ça ça se
fait avec la pointe de la langue il m'a
dit ah oui quand j'étais petit j'avais
pris une prise électrique pas une prise
en fil électrique où il y avait du
courant et je me suis très gravement
brûlé au bout de la langue tout peut
influencer en fait notre manière de
parler notre voix et est-ce que notre
voix peut nous trahir bien sûr
heureusement si on n'arrivait pas à
faire passer nos émotions dans nos
voiles nous ne serions plus des êtres
humains nous trahir oui mais aussi
nous trahir ça dit quelque chose de nous
qui n'est d'ailleurs pas forcément plus
la vérité de nous que ce que nous sommes
au quotidien mais ça dit effectivement
quelque chose de nous et c'est aussi ce
qui est important après tout une voix
chaleureuse c'est quelque chose qui nous
plaît une voix grinçante ces
fauquenaires qui dit quelque part elle
avait une voix à peu près comme une
roulette de dentiste oui bon c'est
agréable et là nous parlons depuis 5
minutes et je commence à avoir un petit
peu peur de ce que vous allez découvrir
de moi merci en tout cas Gabriel bergonu
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et si
ce thème de la voix des accents vous
intéresse sachez que vous avez jusqu'à
dimanche soir pour visiter l'exposition
La Voix l'expo qui vous parle c'est à la
Cité des sciences et de l'Industrie à
Paris vous pourrez percer là-bas tous
les secrets des voix et des accents
le Berry et ses champs à perte de vue la
carte postale semble idyllique et
pourtant cette campagne se vide petit à
petit de ses habitants et en particulier
de ses agriculteurs
Mathieu a 28 ans et cherche à
s'installer depuis plusieurs années en
désespoir de cause il a fondé son
entreprise de prestation de service
agricole
gonzac 33 ans s'est installé mais c'est
considérablement endetté il mène de
front deux métiers pour survivre
Damien 21 ans et lycéens il se prépare à
affronter la complexité de
l'installation
tous ces jeunes agriculteurs veulent
avoir leur propre terre et s'installer à
leur compte
bienvenue dans leur monde
oui allô Mathieu cyprès est un homme
pressé comme toute agriculteur qui se
respecte il part travailler tous les
matins dans les champs des champs qui ne
sont pourtant pas les siens Mathieu est
prestataire il travaille chez les autres
je suis en train de finir de préparer
un obstacle pour cet après-midi et puis
mon salarié va partir avec Laurent c'est
parti jusqu'à ce soir on organise les
journées un peu au jour le jour
ce mode de vie il l'a choisi à défaut de
pouvoir s'installer le but c'était
d'avoir son exploitation ses terres sont
matériels une femme des enfants trop
d'investissements trop cher il a dû
renoncer du moins provisoirement
j'aurais voulu trouver une exploitation
type 150 hectares céréales etc dans
lequel j'aurais pu vivre correctement
enfin à peu près
je pouvais pas donc j'ai plutôt monté
une entreprise très agricole je pouvais
pas parce que c'était financier compteur
4 familial tes parents sont pour la
culture c'est assez compliqué
d'une part financière d'autre part pour
accéder aux fonciers et c'est pour ça du
coup j'ai monté une société commerciale
donc qui fait de la prestation de
service donc je travaille pour les
agriculteurs qui sont pas équipés
pour le moment c'est donc un nomade de
l'agriculture le but étant d'économiser
pour pouvoir acheter un peu de terre en
attendant le marathon continue en route
pour le sud du Cher ou Matthieu doit
faucher des prix tu reprends le la
parcelle
tu vas atterrir au fond
Mathieu n'est pas un cas isolé
s'installer beaucoup y aspire mais peu
peuvent se le permettre si vous voulez
on a beau et t'aider quand ça vaut une
fortune ça vaut une fortune au moment tu
plafonnes les aides c'est normal là le
foncier je vous dis il a doublé en
disant tu peux rien ça tu peux rien et
puis on a des structures qui sont de
moins en moins transmissibles comprenez
et les structures qui arrivent à 5 6 7 5
vous voulez qu'un jeune il reprenne ça
c'est pas possible c'est impossible il y
a quelques temps de là on avait des
domaines en fermage qu'un jeune poids
s'installer dessus sur 80 hectares
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est plus le
cas on trouve plus de ça salut les
grosses structures des grosses
structures des grosses structures quoi
alors c'est bien c'est bien pour les
gens qui le font mais bon après il faut
laisser un peu de place au genou
des prix qui flambent des domaines
agricoles géants impossibles à reprendre
les jeunes comme Matthieu sont dans une
impasse aujourd'hui quand on est pas
fils d'agriculture il faut être nanti
pour s'acheter des terres
les courbes sont éloquantes en 15 ans le
foncier agricole a doublé en France et
la région Centre et le Cher n'échappe
pas la tendance dans ce département le
prix de l'hectare est passé de 2500 à
plus de 4700 euros en 13 ans
en cause il y a notamment l'urbanisation
les villes grignotent les campagnes les
terres qui restent sont donc plus chères
le moindre lopin mis en vente attire les
convoitises et les agriculteurs qui
partent en retraite sont placés devant
un dilemme vendrin jeune ou aux voisins
qui cherchent à s'étendre
bon là vous voyez bon ici c'était les
les génisses de 3 ans qui était là en
attente d'être mis
au taureau quoi c'était Jacques charrue
a pris sa retraite l'an dernier il a
voulu transmettre son exploitation à un
jeune mais sa succession ne s'est pas
passé comme prévu
j'aurais bien aimé voir des vaches
encore un peu ici
mais bon
c'est comme ça
pourquoi il y en a plus de vache ici
parce que ben on n'a pas réussi le
repreneur a pas réussi à avoir les les
prairies et il a pas pu reprendre le
sheptel quoi comme beaucoup
d'agriculteurs Jacques charrue n'était
pas propriétaire de toutes ces terres il
n'en possédait en fait que 10%, 20
hectares sur 200 pas suffisant pour
vivre le reste il le louait différents
propriétaires et l'un d'entre eux par
peur des impayés n'a pas souhaité louer
à un jeune
moi mon but premier c'était
l'installation d'un jeune
un jeune hors cas de familial en plus et
puis qui qui démarre avec zéro c'était
vraiment une installation propre
c'était pas un agrandissement j'estime
que il y a pas assez d'installation de
jeûne et que bah il faut voir dans
l'avenir ce qu'on est encore des
agriculteurs dans 20 ou 25 ans qu'il ne
reste pas cas ou deux agriculteurs par
par commune il faut il faut installer
des jeunes et même tous les agriculteurs
vieillissent donc faut il faut qu'il y a
des jeunes qui prennent reprennent le
flambeau résultat des courses
l'exploitation a été démembrée la partie
céréalière a bien été reprise par le
jeune mais les vaches ont disparu des
stabulations
alors quand j'ai débuté moi mais il y a
très longtemps j'avais commencé avec des
moutons et après j'ai acheté des vaches
et j'ai monté un cheptel
j'ai tellement même je suis arrivé en
2013 à avoir 150 150 têtes comme Jacques
charrue un agriculteur sur deux va
partir en retraite dans les 5 ans et
seulement 60% seront remplacés par un
jeune la plupart des terres laissés par
les retraités serviront donc à
l'agrandissement des exploitations
voisines ce que combat la Chambre
d'Agriculture du Cher
quand on a des exploitations qui sont
viables et qui permettent un jeune de
s'installer c'est toujours plus
intéressant à mon sens d'installer
quelqu'un que d'agrandir des gens autour
donc certes des fois la confrontation
elle est importante puisque il y a des
gens qui ont des petites exploitations
donc récupérer un peu et c'est important
pour leur viabilité mais si la structure
le permet l'installation est toujours le
sens favorable pour l'agriculture du
département et je pense qu'il faut
vraiment dire que si on transmet pas les
exploitations et ben demain on aura plus
d'agriculteurs donc c'est quand même
c'est quand même important ce que il y a
l'agriculture mais il y a aussi toutes
les
tout ce qui tourne autour de
l'agriculture dans le département on a
quand même des comment dire
désorganisations autour des agriculteurs
qui sont importantes et qui créent
l'emploi donc si on a plus
d'agriculteurs ces emplois là on les
aura pas non plus
dans ce contexte certains parviennent
tout de même à s'installer mais à quel
prix
gonzac bachelier est plutôt du genre
têtu quand il a un projet dans la tête
il va au bout il s'est donc installé en
mars 2013 dans cette belle exploitation
de 200 hectares près de Levet en pleine
Champagne berrichonne il a été installé
par la SAFER société qui gère le foncier
agricole problème il n'a pas pu discuter
le prix et c'est beaucoup beaucoup
endetté
pour s'installer le matériel on le
reprend souvent de fois beaucoup plus
cher qu'il ne vaut donc pour X raison
et
autant autant de remboursements
d'empreintes vous avez c'est autant
d'argent que vous sortez de votre poche
que c'est du salaire que vous vous
versez pas donc
le marchand de bien c'est des frais non
négociable c'est des frais très élevés
de safer c'est des frais très élevés
c'est non négociable et le matériel
c'est non négociable si vous voulez moi
dans ma position j'étais face à un
agriculteur qui était déjà installé
depuis longtemps qui avait des moyens
d'acheter d'exploitation sans difficulté
au prix
donc si je voulais absolument
m'installer chose que je voulais il a
fallu que je fasse la même chose que
j'accepte les conditions
les bâtiments les terres le matériel le
marchand bien et la SAFER en tout plus
d'un million d'euros à débourser des
annuités massues lui tombent dessus
aujourd'hui
moi c'est un tracteur à 100000 euros à
200000 je peux pas récolter mes cultures
donc
ça ça appartient à la banque
donc le le gros sacrifice qu'il faut
faire c'est qu'il faut avoir une
activité à côté sinon j'ai pas de
salaire
et ça ça va durer
le moins de temps je l'espère mais je
pense que ça va durer encore au moins
trois quatre ans là vous êtes dans
quelle situation financière en fait
situation délicate
situation délicate j'arrive pas à faire
face à toutes mes annuités de
remboursement
liés à l'exploitation il y a certaines
choses qui sont
financées en court terme donc des choses
que je capitalise pas et
personnellement ma vie de famille
empathie et
tout empathie quoi la ferme financière
financièrement avec la Poste
suffisamment d'argent et personnellement
à un moment donné je suis moins
disponible dans mon activité salariale
donc j'ai moins de revenus
donc tout est tout est difficile
bon ça est donc bien agriculteur mais à
mi-temps sa force de travail il la
partage entre son exploitation et son
métier de vendeur d'engins agricole ce
jour-là il se rend chez un client pour
conclure la vente d'un tracteur
ça reste voilà indispensable ça si je
fais pas cette activité annexe
mon banquier pour personnel va m'écrire
en rouge sur son tableau et il va avoir
un téléphone rouge il va m'appeler très
très souvent ça va pas bien se passer
surendettée ou sans exploitation ça
n'empêche pas les jeunes agriculteurs de
se mobiliser pour essayer de changer les
choses tous les ans via leur syndicats
ils organisent des forums pour réunir
les futurs retraités les jeunes pour
faciliter la transmission des terres
l'occasion de convier les banques et les
organismes agricoles et parmi ces
organismes il en est inqui a un rôle clé
la SAFER mais au fait c'est quoi la
SAFER c'est une société privée avec une
mission d'intérêt général créée dans les
années 60 pour moderniser l'agriculture
une de ses principales missions aider
les jeunes à s'installer pour ça elle a
une stratégie
alors aujourd'hui là ça fait travail
avec des investisseurs
qui portent le foncier ce qui permet aux
jeunes de reprendre les terres en
location ces investisseurs c'est des
gens qui veulent le faire des
déplacements dans l'immobilier ce sont
des chefs d'entreprise ce sont
éventuellement
des développements financiers qui
cherchent à diversifier leur patrimoine
la Terre est devenue une valeur refuge
un placement qui double en 15 ans attire
forcément les investisseurs la SAFER se
sert de pour installer des jeunes mais
ce type d'installation pourrait aussi
faire grimper le prix du foncier
aujourd'hui là ça faire n'est pas
responsable de de ce qui peut se passer
au niveau de l'évolution du foncier
aujourd'hui on intervient
systématiquement en amont des opérations
avec des discussions des négociations de
manière à maîtriser l'évolution du
foncier en aucun cas on peut on peut
rendre responsable un organisme plus
qu'un autre du prix du foncier
la SAFER compte en tout cas sur cette
stratégie car depuis plusieurs années
déjà son action est remise en question
notamment par la Cour des comptes moins
de 10% d'installation de jeunes en 2012
dérive
inefficacité sa cote de popularité est
au plus bas
85% des agriculteurs ne lui font plus
confiance d'après un sondage réalisé par
le magazine terres agricole en 2012
l'institution semble dépasser par la loi
de l'offre et de la demande il y a ce
qu'on dit le prix officiel et le prix
officiel en fait tout le monde nous dira
par exemple sur Bourges oui monétaire
la SAFER a contenu on est sur des prix
de 6-7000 euros la réalité terrain est
beaucoup plus forte
à l'accès du foncier qui est énorme
il y a des acheteurs il y a pas de
vendeurs il y a des acheteurs il y a une
terre qui sidère il y a 15 personnes
dessus donc c'est l'offre et la demande
après les pour nous on est beaucoup
moins cher que les étrangers beaucoup
moins cher que la Belgique que
l'Allemagne que la Hollande même que
l'Italie et l'Espagne donc il y a aucune
raison que le prix baisse il va
continuer à monter
les prix du foncier n'étant pas amené à
baisser il faut trouver des alternatives
au lycée agricole on prépare les jeunes
à affronter ce milieu complexe tout
spécialement ce qui évolue hors cadre
familial c'est-à-dire qu'ils n'ont pas
de parents agriculture depuis une
vingtaine d'années ils sont en passe de
devenir majoritaire dans les classes
Damien fait partie de ces jeunes il
passe aujourd'hui son oral de fin
d'année
monsieur Vincent et sa femme en 60 ans
et donc dans une démarche de
transmission progressive il souhaiterait
s'associer avec un jeune pour leur
transmettre progressivement les parts
sociales de l'exploitation
l'association d'un agriculteur avec un
jeune c'est ça la solution le principe
est simple l'agriculteur a monté une
société pour gérer son exploitation le
jeune va donc acheter des parts de cette
société pour s'installer tout en douceur
pour m'installer progressivement ça fait
des investissements qui sont moins
lourds au départ à l'installation faut
pas se le cacher c'est quand même des
sommes d'argent qui sont assez
conséquentes
même si ça reste encore raisonnable à
reprise de part sociale mais oui c'est
au départ on se dit ce qu'on va réussir
à rembourser
les l'endettement qu'on dans lequel on
s'engage
Damien sera donc associé le risque est
plus limité les banques rassurées un
modèle plébiscité au sein de
l'établissement il y a déjà des jeunes
qui étaient en apprentissage qui ont
suit une période de salariat chez leur
employeur chez la personne qui les a
formé pour aboutir ensuite à terme à une
installation dans le cadre d'une de part
de prise dans la société agricole
constituée pour des jeunes qui sont hors
cadres familial ça peut ressembler
effectivement un parcours idéal cela dit
il n'y a pas de recette miracle il y a
toutes les solutions à partir du moment
elle correspondent aux individus peuvent
être positives et intéressantes
autre modèle possible acheter plus petit
c'est l'idée de Julien broutard il est
informateur au lycée agricole mais il a
décidé de passer à la pratique il va
donc élever de la volaille et des
moutons dans une petite ferme du sud du
Cher diversité petite surface comme dans
le temps à contre-pied du modèle
dominant
le premier avantage en termes
d'installation c'est de d'être sur
quelque chose qui va être gérable seul
qui va être remboursable seul sans qui
est de capitaux qui viennent de
l'extérieur là alors les capitaux ils
viennent de la banque mais juste en
faisant appel
auprès comme chacun pourrait faire un
prêt pour acheter sa maison juste en
faisant appel à ça les banques sont
prêtes à suivre le projet
moi c'est c'était ma façon de voir quoi
après il y en a d'autres pour qui leur
façon de voir c'est d'avoir
l'exploitation qui va être la plus
grande possible faire des économies
d'échelle faire faire des cultures en
nombre réduit pour pour aller pour aller
à l'essentiel quoi
moi mon essentiel c'est d'avoir d'avoir
une exploitation qui soit tenable par
mois et
qui soit un élément de la vie du
de la vie du territoire c'est ça qui
était le plus important c'est d'avoir
quelque chose
où je puisse me retrouver
ces moutons et ses poulets Julien les
vendra en circuit court sur les marchés
dans les drives fermiers ou par Internet
plus coûteux pour le consommateur les
circuits courts sont aussi plus
rémunérateurs pour le producteur des
débouchés innovants qui peuvent faire
vivre ces petites structures
il y a une place pour pour tout le monde
quoi et globalement la surface agricole
française elle diminue par
l'urbanisation par le passage des routes
et tout ça et il faut qu'on soit qu'on
soit compétitif quoi il faut pour
pouvoir continuer à vivre et que
l'agriculture française elle nourrissent
la vie française il faut qu'on continue
à être productif et intelligemment
produire intelligemment c'est l'enjeu
des politiques agricoles de demain la
nouvelle loi d'avenir pour l'agriculture
l'alimentation et la forêt a été
définitivement adoptée le 11 septembre
dernier elle va contraindre la SAFER à
mieux assumer ses missions elle prévoit
aussi de limiter les agrandissements
pour faciliter les installations une
réforme qui va a priori dans le bon sens
le maintien des jeunes sur le territoire
est à ce prix
prendre racine c'était un magazine
proposé par Nicolas Chigot et meliore
mouamma le reportage qui suit nous
emmène sur un terrain sensible polémique
pour ceux qui sont concernés de près
épineux pour le gouvernement le dossier
du travail du dimanche n'en finit pas de
diviser les politiques les salariés et
les clients il y a un an des enseignes
de bricolage frondeuses en Île-de-France
avaient été condamné à fermer boutique
le dimanche et voilà que le débat est
relancé la question sera même discutée
dans le projet de loi sur la croissance
qui est en cours d'élaboration Antoine
Marguet et Jean-Yves blanc ont fait les
magasins le soir tard le week-end ils
sont allés voir aussi comment certains
de nos voisins européens avaient réglé
cette question voici leur enquête
dans notre société où le rythme est
toujours plus rapide faut-il changer les
règles du travail du dimanche et
autorisé tous les magasins à ouvrir pour
cette économie qui a rédigé un rapport
sur le sujet en 2008 c'est plus un choix
de société qu'un choix économique
très certainement que l'effet sur
l'emploi serait extrêmement modeste à
supposer qu'un effet positif parce que
n'oublions pas que aussi des effets
négatifs à l'ouverture systématique du
commerce le dimanche et que les les
coûts les coûts augmentent non seulement
parce que il faut ouvrir 7 jours au lieu
de 6 souvent il faudra dédommager les
salariés donc des salaires plus élevés
c'est coûts plus élevés il faut bien les
retrouver quelque part donc on va les
retrouver sur les étiquettes donc un
indice des prix qui va qui va en subir
des conséquences un impact sur le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages donc sur la
consommation donc voyez les les
mécanismes induits par tout ça sont
extrêmement complexes et il faut se
garder d'avoir des raisonnements un peu
un peu trop simpliste
alors comment font nos voisins européens
en Grande-Bretagne c'est un compromis à
l'anglaise qui a été voté les magasins
sont ouverts le dimanche depuis 1994 ce
qui fait dire à ce journaliste anglais
que la France a 20 ans de retard
l'ouverture du dimanche est très
encadrée parce que à l'époque en 1986
c'était mort qui avait proposé à débat
pour ouvrir le dimanche donc ça va pas
être évoqué au Parlement et il a fallu
attendre 1994 et l'arrivée de John
maidjan donc le successeur de Morgane
pour un nouveau débat au Parlement qui a
été accepté à condition que les
boutiques ne voient que 6 heures par
jour le dimanche entre 9h du matin et
18h on peut ouvrir quand on voudrait
mais pour une période qui n'excède pas 6
heures le dimanche dans la très
catholique Italie les grandes surfaces
peuvent ouvrir le dimanche depuis le 1er
janvier 2012 tout peut se concilier le
matin on va la messe et l'après-midi au
centre commercial
une révolution imaginée par le
gouvernement Monti pour stimuler la
consommation mais qui n'a pas permis à
l'Italie de sortir de la crise
les conséquences de ce choix n'ont pas
été celles que Monty espéré mais il y a
eu un autre phénomène qu'aujourd'hui ces
grandes surfaces ouvertes le dimanche
sont devenus aussi un point pour se
retrouver il y a de bistrots il y a des
magasins il y a des
endroits où les enfants peuvent jouer
s'amuser donc sont devenus
la petite vacance du week-end
retour à Paris où le débat porte aussi
sur les horaires de soirée notamment
dans la capitale
avec leur rythme décalé de nombreux
consommateurs se sont habitués aux
fermetures tardives
je trouve que tout devrait être ouvert
le dimanche le soir jusqu'à 23h ça
serait génial une formule qui est séduit
Aurore jeune cadre dans un secteur où
l'on ne compte pas ses heures une adepte
des courses en soirée
et c'est vrai que avoir quelque chose
d'ouvert au moins jusqu'à 22h ça permet
aussi de rester serein sur les sorties
de bureau d'arriver de pouvoir faire ses
courses en rentrant chez soi le soir
pourtant les syndicats multiplient les
actions justice contre les enseignes qui
ferment après 21h leur légal prévu par
la loi
Apple Uniqlo Sephora Carrefour Monoprix
tous ont été condamnés pour la CGT le
travail en soirée nuit à la santé des
salariés
toutes ces études récentes convergent
pour dire que le travail de nuit diminue
la durée de vie moyenne des salariés
accroît un certain nombre de maladies
graves type cancers en particulier le
cancer du sein et dans le commerce c'est
une population essentiellement féminine
80% de femmes dans les magasins donc il
y a quand même un gros gros risque
autour de ça il y a aussi des problèmes
d'accident de travail plus fréquents et
plus dangereux plus graves le soir
il faut dire que pour les salariés les
compensations sont peu motivantes car
ces heures de nuit ne sont pas
obligatoirement mieux rémunérés en fait
la loi ne prévoit qu'une contrepartie en
repos
en pratique elles sont tout de même pays
entre 10 et 20% de plus dans le commerce
mais beaucoup de salariés n'ont pas le
choix chez Apple Stanislas a porté la
bataille de la fermeture à 21h
vous avez un planning vous devez le
respecter il n'y a pas de d'alternative
c'est-à-dire que les salariés qui ne
souhaitent pas qui ne souhaitaient pas
aller au-delà de 21h et bien ils étaient
invités à quitter l'entreprise
mais avec ces fermetures c'est Paris qui
risque de s'endormir un handicap pour
certains quartiers touristiques comme
les Champs-Élysées jusqu'à 80 000
personnes arpentes la plus belle avenue
du monde en soirée
20% du chiffre d'affaires sont fait le
soir et ces 20% là ils vont partir
ailleurs il y a des Parisiens qui
achètent mais il y a beaucoup d'achat
d'impulsion les Champs-Élysées c'est pas
une destination de course de besoins
c'est un commerce de de d'enseigne de
plaisir donc c'est de l'achat
d'impulsion donc ce qui n'est pas fait
le soir il n'est pas fait le lendemain
sur le lendemain il est fait à Londres
il est fait à Milan il est fait
éventuellement à Tokyo et puis enfin
est-ce que le premier pays touristique
du monde a raison d'envoyer comme signal
que le soir à 21h on ferme
reste une certitude pour le travail de
nuit comme pour celui du dimanche la loi
a de plus en plus de mal à s'appliquer
sereinement
je précise que dans le projet de loi sur
la croissance qui sera débattue d'ici à
la fin de l'année la question du travail
du dimanche ne sera pas abordée dans sa
généralité mais seulement dans les zones
touristiques et cela veut dire que le
débat est loin d'être terminé notre
émission elle se termine mais elle
continue à vivre sur internet sur notre
site sans trois points France 3 points
fr vous retrouvez les différents
magazines que l'on vous a proposé ce
soir et aussi les anciens numéros à
revoir en ligne
tout de suite votre soirée continue sur
France 3 centre avec un très beau
documentaire consacré aux ateliers Loire
les maîtres du vitrail à Chartres passer
une très belle fin de soirée une belle
nuit et rendez-vous le mois prochain
vendredi 24 octobre même heure pour de
nouvelles enquêtes au centre